you got this movie coming out or it's
out now it's out on digital and on
demand and i saw the trailer for this
and it looked intense as [ __ ]
yeah and uh
neon lights yeah now you get to work or
she gets you get yeah you get to work
with brenna brenna coach your daughter
and you know a lot of times you hear you
know somebody's working with their
daughter this she's like a star
like she's she's went to tish she's done
so much theater she is she knows what
the hell she's doing yeah she's the real
deal this kid she um you know dai and i
my wife and i we we didn't
push our kids away or to
anything when they were growing up it
was letting them discover what they
liked and loved and
reading they're both so smart kyla you
know she's trying to save america god
bless her she works in l.a county with
janason she's a deputy supervisor she's
a big shot and she's with mental health
and his sheriff's department the firemen
and homeless i mean she's she's in it in
la county 12 million people she's got a
big job and she loves it and she really
really
is caring about america in the right way
being such a liberal it's uh
she's got a lot of work ahead of her and
we're proud of her brenna who's as smart
as kyla she was an actor from four five
six years old i mean she just knew it
she was shy she's beautiful she's funny
anyway so she auditions for tish
from her high school in pasadena she
gets in uh she's in new york and you
know michael it's like come on [ __ ] off
it's like 65 grand a year
and that doesn't even buy you a
starbucks
and if her dad is not on sons of anarchy
she's not going to new york she's going
to victoria or saskatchewan or seattle
somewhere you know i i couldn't afford
you know come on right but i happen to
be lucky to be on a big tv show and i'm
making money so fine she goes there four
years
at the end of the fourth year michael
they do a
a duo
it's a one-act 90-minute play sarah de
la brand new play called the wolves
so all the seniors it's about nine girls
on a soccer team
a mom comes in at the end of the play
and they had one showing of what they
were doing this is the final project
here she is saying bye
i flew i saw it diana couldn't go i'm in
the audience
i am
so blown away at all the girls we're all
crying at the end this is a juggernaut
play and they knew it
cut two
six months later they're finally gonna
do the wolves in poughkeepsie and from
poughkeepsie it's gonna go up broadway
if it's any good it'll go to broadway so
brenda has to re-audition and she's
going through all the stress
all the stress same part she's perfect
for it and i go i'm telling you right
now brenna and this is what you and i
had to deal with michael i i still do
but they're gonna look for a name
her part was one of the three leads of
the nine girls they're gonna look for a
name so don't don't feel bad if you
don't get it i got a good feeling about
it but you did you know so she did one
and she did a call back all these
producers were sitting there whatever
whatever then we had to wait two weeks
and she finally got the call that the
part was hers cut to a summer of
poughkeepsie couldn't get a ticket goes
to the duke theater couldn't get a
ticket all these movie stars are
starting to see this play the walls the
wolves the wolves it gets called um one
of the greatest plays in new york in the
past 25 new york times new york times
correct
and so brenna gets called out in all
anyway they end up winning an ob and a
drama desk award for the ensemble of all
the actors on it
all nine girls win these incredible
awards she goes you know right to
another play in san diego another place
somewhere else then she comes and
doesn't play with dad i did jerusalem by
jazz butterworth i almost died on stage
every night mark rylance is doing it
again right now in london i flew to see
him we had dinner i saw it twice hugs
all around he gave me the baton four
years ago when i was preparing to play
this guy i took a year to prepare the
accent went to london five times the
whole deal is a long story but brenna
was in that play with dad cut to this
moving neon lights michael
when this movie it was during the
pandemic nothing's happening early fall
2020. my agent in canada i've always
told gail that's why i've never fired
her i love her to death i've hired more
american american agents over the years
but i'm with a really good one now
sharing conan i love her to death
uh my management company's pretty cool
too maine state anyway
i get this call from gail she goes
you're not gonna do this movie i go
what's it called neon lights why
it's just really dark it's it's i can't
get through it i said well send it to me
so they sent it to me
and sure enough it's about mental health
right and it's about it's about it's a
psychological thriller slash horror
small cast it's in one man mansion the
house has a character on its own i play
a guy i can't say too much about it
because it's a very surprise when you
watch the movie anyway there was a
perfect part for me and a perfect part
for brenna and i had to read it twice to
really understand what this guy dena
abraham who wrote it and starred in and
was talking about
i said i would do it they said can we
have brenda to us you'd have to call her
and see if she'll she like she read it
she plays a shrink she's never played a
part like that before she's really i
like an angel in this movie
um she says yes so we're working
together for the first time
you